all will be one spoiler season is upon
us and one of the best commander cards
has already been spoiled let's take a
look at mondrak glory Dominus mondrak is
a four Mana legendary forexian horror
and wizards has already confirmed
they're effectively aforexian God
mondrak says if one or more tokens would
be created under your control twice that
many are created instead and for one
generic aforexion white aforexion white
sacrifice two other artifacts and All
Creatures put an indestructible counter
on mondrak and of course for Axion Mana
can either be paid with two life or mana
and to top it off there are four four
okay can we just take this in for a
second
Wizards has just given us an anointed
procession that we can cast from the
command zone now yes we do have address
and Nev but adrix and Nev can't give
themselves indestructible for
effectively one Mana now before we get
into the tokens let's quickly talk about
that indestructible ability
so mondrak doesn't gain indestructible
they get an indestructible counter
meaning we now have counter Shenanigans
two cards that instantly come to mind
one budget and one not so budget the
budget option is nesting grounds this
land lets us move a counter from one
permanent to any other permanent
allowing us to make anything
indestructible
not only that
the mujin cycle from neon kamagawa care
about indestructible counters so for
Just Two mana and four life return you
can constantly refresh the miogen's
ability
and coincidentally the white miogen just
happens to make a number of tokens equal
to the number of permanents you control
and with mondrak in play well you get
twice that many
now the more expensive option is the
ozolith the osolith is a one Mana
artifact that says whenever a creature
you control leaves the battlefield if it
had a counter on it put those counters
on the ozolith and at the beginning of
combat on your turn if the ozolith has
counters on it you may move all those
counters from the osliff onto Target
creature
so if mondrak does get exiled with their
indestructible counter you can simply
move that counter to the ozolith and
move it back to mondrak when you play
them again or just to another creature
and don't forget forexia all will be one
has a bunch of new proliferate cards
that can abuse these counters too
so tokens mono white has no shortage of
ways to make Creature tokens and buff
and protect them
Grand Crescendo is an ex-white instant
that creates X11 green and white citizen
tokens as well as making all of your
creatures indestructible
Marshall coup is an ex-white sorcery
that generates X11 soldiers and if x is
five or more you get to destroy all
other creatures
want to make just a butt ton of tokens
well look no further than storm heard a
10 Mana sorcery that generates a number
of 1-1 flying Pegasus creatures equal to
your life total and if you have a way to
give them haste well someone is
definitely dying perhaps even the whole
table moving on from instants and
sorceries next up we have some creatures
that can help you generate even more
tokens the final of faith is a five Mana
five five with vigilance that lets you
pay two life instead of a white Mana for
any of your white permanent spells and
when you cast a white permanent spell it
creates a 1-1 white Soldier token and if
you're not up for paying life simply
just play lands and let miria Angel and
felidar Retreat do the work for you
amiria Angel is a 4 Mana 3-3 with flying
that generates a 1-1 flying bird token
whenever a land enters the battlefield
under your control
and felidar Retreat is both an excellent
offensive and defensive enchantment for
four Mana you get an enchantment that
says landfall whenever a land enters the
battlefield under your control create a
2-2 white Cat Beast
or put a plus one plus one counter on
each creature you control they gain
vigilance until end of turn
both of these landfall cards are great
as they effectively require no
additional input from you you simply
continue your normal play pattern of
playing lands and casting spells and
they generate a bunch of value for you
to support all of these tokens you'll be
generating let's check out these cards
oh and speaking of supporting you can
support the channel by quickly hitting
the like button if you're finding this
video helpful in any way
anyways to start I think mirror entity
is severely underrated for three Mana
you get a 1-1 change length that has a
pay X until end of turn creatures you
control have base power and toughness XX
meaning you can pump all of your
creatures to as much power as you have
Mana which for a budget go wide strategy
is excellent root-born defenses is a
three Mana instant that clones one of
your tokens as well as making all of
your creatures gain indestructible until
Ender turn and if you're sticking with a
mono white strategy Brave the elements
gives all of your white creatures
protection from a chosen color giving
you an excellent defensive option or the
ability to push through with a
potentially unblockable attack
now there's one more thing about mondrak
that we need to make clear their token
ability doesn't say if one or more
creature tokens would be created no
mondrak doubles any type of token that
gets created
so the most busted white card in all of
Commander smothering tithe is absolutely
nuts here and of course we can't forget
the easily overlooked Smuggler's share
which is a three minor enchantment that
cuts Us in on the share of extra Mana or
card draw our opponents get each turn
search the premise is a nice way to
generate some additional card draw that
white generally lacks and if you're
going to be generating both Clues and
treasures Academy manufacturer is
another awesome pickup so what do you
think of mondrak I'll certainly be
hunting for a copy of him on launch day
do you think they should be a commander
or just part of the 99
let me know in the comments down below
thanks for watching and stay tuned for
more Commander content